remember that time when sports
illustrated was supposed to be a sports
magazine yeah that was funny
sports illustrated i was i was a long
time subscriber to sports illustrated
uh i will acknowledge that as a
religious person i always
took the option you can do this of
calling up sports illustrated and not
getting the swimsuit edition
which was you know basically material
for teenage boys
i would always call up sports
illustrated and uh and say add an issue
to the end of my subscription and just
don't send the swimsuit edition
but the swimsuit edition has been a long
time thing for sports illustrated and
always
basically it was hot models and body
paint on the beach that's always
what it was well now sports illustrated
because it has become another preserve
of the woke
has decided that it is time to cram down
on red-blooded american males
a particular perception of female beauty
namely dudes
so there is a there is a trans woman
who has now been featured on the cover
of sports illustrated
this is the trans woman whose name is
lena bloom
now layna bloom has had surgeries and
hormone treatment
and looks physically like a woman right
which by the way seems rather
transphobic to me
because if you truly sports illustrated
wanted to make the case
that trans women are women and trans
women shouldn't have to look
like swimsuit models in fact trans women
i mean this seems fat phobic to me
trans women should actually look like
laurel hubbard why isn't laurel hubbard
on the cover of the sports illustrated
swimsuit dish you know the new zealand
weightlifter
who's now going to be weightlifting in
the olympics and has more to do with
sports than than elena bloom
and why is it that that only a a
trans woman who looks like a
stereotypical swimsuit model
in a low-cut bikini is now considered
a fitting figure for the cover of sports
illustrated seems
very very fat phobic uh very transphobic
frankly because it seems to suggest that
the only trans women who ought to be
treated
as as women are trans women who conform
to all
stereotypes regarding women in elena
bloom my understanding is has had all of
the
surgeries to fake female body parts
but as we know that is to to suggest
that that is
a requirement of trans women to be
treated as women is violative of their
of their norms it is violative of
decency
so truly sports illustrated has not gone
far enough until sports illustrated
suggests that red-blooded american males
get used to the idea
of a trans woman who looks exactly like
a man because as we know
sex is really all in your head gender is
really all in your head
and the person on the cover of sports
illustrated shouldn't have to be
a a swimsuit model looking male
masquerading as female it should be a
dude with twig and berries
and chest hair and no fake breasts
being treated essentially the same as a
woman that's that's when we know we've
reached parity i think
i think that's the really important
thing now look the reason that sports
illustrated is doing this is for the
bleeps and giggles
right they are doing it to push forward
the quote-unquote social justice agenda
the idea being that if they push forward
a biological man on the cover of sports
illustrated as a woman
and if you say no even if that
biological man has had many surgeries
and hormone treatments to look like a
woman that is still a biological man
that if you say that then this means
that you are somehow
transphobic or if you even though that
is the biological truth
or that you're you're mean and vicious
look sports illustrated's a free
company can do what it wants right it's
a private company
but there is obviously a social attempt
to normalize the idea
that biological men who look like women
are in fact women which of course is a
wild degradation of what it actually
means to be a woman
a word with an actual definition so it's
pretty obvious what sports illustrated
is doing here
but sports illustrated didn't stop there
so one of the other
models on the cover of si swimsuit
edition
is of course the the tremendous megan
the stallion
because of her tremendous history with
sports
according to sports illustrated swimsuit
edition megan the stallion is no
stranger to magazine covers but the
rapper and songwriter always dreamed of
being on the cover of si swimsuit which
is a weird dream
she remembers as a young girl looking at
the magazine and saying one day this
is going to be me a couple of decades
later the houston native would have
several grammys under her belt and make
history as the first rapper
on the si swimsuit cover and she is the
perfect fit
uh amazing amazing and then finally they
have an athlete on the cover so who is
the athlete who's on the cover
of uh of sports illustrated the athlete
on the cover of sports illustrated is
naomi osaka
now you'll recall in naomi osaka
withdrew
from one of the tennis majors after a
blow up with the media
in which she just wouldn't do her media
hits and the atp
the the tennis professional association
they said you need to do that
right it is your job part of your job as
a tennis player is to deal with the
media because this is true in all sports
you're supposed to do the press
conferences
and naomi osaka then went out and she
claimed that she suffered from deep
anxiety not diagnosed anxiety just deep
anxiety and dealing with the media
okay fair enough if you suffer from like
i know people i'm very close to people
who have anxiety disorders that ought to
be treated with kid gloves
you have to make provision for that
obviously now i miss i sort of suggested
that that's what was going on
you know what people with anxiety
disorders typically don't
do people who are who are shirking media
attention people who just want to stay
away from the media
and don't want to be involved with me
you know they typically don't do pose
for the cover of i believe time magazine
has now done a cover on naomi osaka and
also sports illustrated
so strange that she doesn't want to take
questions from you know people who ask
critical questions but
if you are doing a sports illustrated
cover or a time magazine cover
then all of a sudden all the hesitancy
goes away and by the way it's not as
though naomi osaka was being asked like
vicious brutal questions
she was being asked questions about like
her performance as a tennis player
says sports illustrated naomi osaka is
no doubt in athletic powerhouse at 23
shields four grand slam titles and is
headed to tokyo to compete in the
olympics this comes after defeating
former u.s open
champion samantha stozer in her wta tour
debut at just 16.
it's her strength and power off the
court that makes naomi a true legend
she's raised awareness about racial
injustice human rights and mental health
cementing her as one of the most
outspoken professional tennis players
outspoken except when she won't talk to
anybody who you know has a question
my favorite quote from her time magazine
cover piece is she suggested i just
don't understand why anyone would
disagree with me like she
she said she was surprised that anyone
would disagree with her about her
very left-wing view of race in the
united states
she was named one of 2020 sports
illustrated sports persons of the year
for her activism was on time's annual
list of 100 most influential people
in the world finally
uh there is the sports hillside to take
on elena bloom okay so here is what the
uh the sports illustrated swimsuit
edition says well
lena bloom began her rise remember elena
bloom's biological man
began her rise to fame in the ballroom
dance community and has since broken
numerous barriers in the modeling world
she was one of the few openly
transgender models to walk the runway
during new york fashion week in 2017
and was the first transgender woman of
color to appear in vogue india and how
about acting yes she's tackling that too
laina made her acting debut in the film
port authority marking the first film in
khan film festival history that featured
a transgender woman of color in a
leading role now lana makes history yet
again
as the first transgender cover model in
sports illustrated swimsuit history
and the first trans person of color to
appear on our pages
more importantly the 27 year old uses
this platform to speak about acceptance
love and change she's passionate about
inspiring others to love themselves and
be who they want to be unless they're a
dude who just wants a biological woman
in which case they are a vicious brutal
sexist
that would be that'd be terrible so say
the editors
among the many things we've learned over
the past 18 months is how much we value
being part of a community
how much we miss that interaction when
it's taken away this issue represents
the culmination of our powerful
community coming together during these
trying times to make history this is
what
the editor says so wonderful stuff i'm
sure that all of the 17 year old boys
who are receiving the sports illustrated
swimsuit edition will be thrilled
uh to see a a man who believes he's a
woman and has
had surgeries to look like a woman on
the cover of the magazine now again
i don't care very much about the sports
illustrated swimsuit edition
just as a cultural marker it seems
significant right
we're not going to play this gas
lighting game or the left does something
they say it's highly significant you
point out that it is highly significant
that we are treating a transgender woman
the same way we would treat an actual
born woman swimsuit model on the cover
of magazines
and then they say how are you even
noticing is it important to you
the sports illustrated cover is
important to me what's important to me
is the mandate that has come down from
our cultural commissars
that we act as though a male who has had
hormone treatments and surgeries is the
full equivalent
to a woman in every way including in
terms of sexual attraction
that is a that is a very interesting and
i think rather unsupportable take in in
actual life
but it's something that the media wished
to cram down for sure for sure